dude that [ __ ] with brendan that was
[ __ ] crazy that was like the worst
game of clue i'd ever seen in the world
dude when you guys did that thing it's
like he had like these fought the files
and the full and you guys had like
missing people in the [ __ ] there was
some guy
beating kids on reddit yeah yeah how do
you i can't even get into my reddit how
do you beat kids yeah like the that was
the [ __ ] the whole thing was
unbelievable the whole thing was
unbelievable and i was just like you
know i don't
i don't want this [ __ ] to be [ __ ]
happening
but it was [ __ ]
i don't know it was pretty [ __ ] yeah
i mean the things they were saying was
like i had i wouldn't even i didn't even
know what the [ __ ] they were talking
about i was like
what reddit and what's going on you know
and they got you're the one
yeah i'm the one what
i mean i don't have a computer
and then it's like i remember like
here's the funny thing brendan doesn't
own a computer
i know i know he doesn't own a computer
he doesn't and then i remember dalia
calling me and going dalia goes you
don't own a computer and i go
i know
right he doesn't know that yeah he
thinks i'm i don't even know how to log
into anything you know anyway you know i
mean and i saw him i've seen him a
couple times and i've been very cordial
you know i mean hopefully
you know we can do this you know i mean
and and get back but oh you don't take a
while i think oh i think you guys are i
mean it's
i've never heard him have any animosity
i don't think he ever does yeah yeah
vernon never really does have any
animosity towards anybody yeah yeah um
which is crazy to think that he came
from a fighting world where they had
that so much animosity that's something
that's always interesting about him but
um
he's one of the hardest workers that i
know but that whole thing was just
[ __ ] absolutely [ __ ] i'm like is
everybody [ __ ] and now it's like it's
like it was like the game of clue though
it was like somebody did it in the
[ __ ] yeah yeah i'm in a mop closet
with a bad server yeah yeah yeah i i
didn't even know you know yeah it was
also like i was at the time when they
made the calls i was on set shooting
something and although it was like it
really just the timing was really weird
and it's like
whenever somebody's like you know accuse
me of something i didn't do right it
feels like
traumatic almost like because it's like
the way they were talking you know i
mean it's like you know they were like
no
bully is the wrong word but they were
just really adamant about it and they
had a lot of feelings behind it well
they believed it i don't think i think
these kind of maybe still do i don't
know well i don't think they was making
it up
you think they still believe it
i don't know
i don't know i feel like they still
believe it bernie and i haven't really
spoken about it much yeah i try not to
talk about either but i don't know but i
thought the whole thing was just
whole i mean it was but it was
interesting too it's all it's all like
the world is just it's all this
it's all this crazy
just drama this play and we're just
taking
different paths through it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one